今日はいい
今日は私はデータサイエンスの話をしようと思います
これだけですね場が盛り上がってとてもやりやすいです
で山なことにですねちょっと違う前反応に入っていくですねあの好反応にそのうちが
あります
データサイエンス
norazo ん
歌聴いたことある方いますよね
ありがとうございます
なんでデータさんしてこの話か実はポリフォニーという会社が無数の無名アーティスト
のデモテープを
データサイズに聞かせてあこれ売れそうだなと思ったのを
人間が聞いてやっとデビューしてます
で次これ獺祭
これ結構有名ですよねあのなぜてらっしゃる方は多いですけど
当時っていうお酒づくりに欠かせない人があのまま逃げちゃったとあのいなくなっ
ちゃったと
で残った方が仕方なくデータを使って美味しいお酒をどうつくるかというのを作ったの
がこれだった
この中で病院行ったことない人いませんじゃ
行ったことある人
そうですよねみんなですよねあのそこで実施される
診断もそうですし処方もそうですし調剤もそうですしすべてがデータサイエンスの結果
ここまできてます
で最近はですねデータ算数によるロボットがセカンドピンを医師に美味しに加えてして
くれるそんな風なサービスも始まっています
医者があた文化じゃないかなーって言ったらこうデータサイエンスのアルゴリズムが
多分違うと思うでみたいな話超です猫
大阪弁じゃないと思うんですけどあのすると
ねそれだけじゃなくてたとえばカジノであったりワインであったり農業であったり
もちろん車よくご存じですよね医療いろんなところでデータサイエンスを生活者として
私たちは経験していますと
じゃ
生活者じゃなくて今度は
作り手働き手としてデータサイエンスが実は人らしく働く
鍵なんだよという風に言ったら皆さんはどう
思うでしょうか
データサイエンスはちょっと冷たい感じがするというか心はそこに通ってない訳だよね
と
人間らしく働く限ってどういうことかなと思う
仕事が奪われるそんな風な
懸念を思う人もいるかもしれませんが私のポジション
立場はデータサイエンスが私たちが人らしく働く
鍵になると思っています
ちょっと大げさなことですね言ってこうみんなのアテンションを引き付けようとしてる
んじゃないかなあこいつって思われるかもしれないんですよ大正解です
あのその遠いなんですが実際私が経験してきた教育とそれから医療の例をちょっと今日
はお話ししようと思うんですけれども
そこで経験してきたことがまさにこれでした
教育というところはあまりデータが使われていません
たとえば病院で皆さんが患者なのに皆様カルテを
手術間に全部シュレッダーで処分されてしまったって言ったらこれ大問題ですよね
記者会見を開くレベルの大問題です
でも学校でも児童に毎年何枚もの答案用紙がシュレッダー行きになってますよね
もちろん
生徒がまだ日にも関わらずどんどん捨てられているとあまり使われないで2学期始まっ
たら2学期の学習指導要領に沿った事業を先生が繰り返すと
私は自分自身あまり授業が学生の頃好きじゃなかったですね
高校の頃とかほとんど勉強しなくてですねプラスで再開とったことがありました
英語も算数もいろいろ苦手でけ
音楽も好きだったんですけど授業は割と苦痛だったですね
ある春休みにアメリカに行こうと思い立って割と勉強して向こうに行って向こうで友達
になった人の家でホームステイをさせてもらって
で帰ってきたと
米レベル上がっていると
で楽しくなるかなと思ったらですねこれ授業のレベルここだと
アメリカに行く前は自分の寺ここだったとすごい普通だったとで帰ってきたらここに
なったっ
て込んだ途端につまらないとなのでふつう館つまらないかのどっちか本当にアベレージ
の
子どもだけが
今の授業の仕組みだとちょうどいいとほとんどいたそうじゃないと
そんな原体験があったもので
私は結局高校を辞めて大検を取って大学に行って就職したわけですが
就職してデータサイエンスをたくさん使うようになって
これ今医療でやっているけれどもひょっとしたら教育でもデータ3 s 使えるんじゃ
ないかな
いうふうに思い
結局行ったのがですねタブレットを配って
家に配って子供に遊んでもらうという話なんですけど
タブレット学習でしょうとよく最近あるよねとなんか coated でこんな偉そう
に話すようななんかそんな話なのかっていう風に思われるかもしれないんですけど
私たちはデータサイエンスを使って子供の潜在能力を最大化することこれをミッション
にしています
でという感じなんですけどあのそういうみんないい事言うよねと言うんですけど結果た
8ですねこれ
右側が
左側が元々学校で行っている
スピード6年間の教育課程6年間で学ぶスピードと思ってくださいこれ私たちの
生徒さん流と平均でだいたい半分倍の速度2分6年間かかって行うものを3年間で
マスターしてしまうスピード a 金でこれですっで進んでいます
これって結構すごいあるた6年間も入らなかった
別に特別な事も病んでるわけじゃなくて平均値がこれだと
ジャン何でこんなふうなことができているのかという話をします
もちろんデータが関わっています
はじめに行ったのはですね子ども一人ひとりの
ビヘイビアを全部を可視化することです
ここに書いてあるのは何月何日のどの時間にどのくらいの所要時間をかけてどの問題に
どんな風に回答したかこれを可視化しました
こうすることでこの子はまだ5歳だけども2年生レベルのことができるとか
図形は得意だけれども文章題が苦手とか文章題は読めてるんだけども
方程式建てられないで方程式建てられるんだけれども
計算ミスをしているそういったことが分かりになりました
可視化ですね
でもこれってちょっと良い塾の先生ぐらいだったらこのくらいわかってるんじゃないの
とおっしゃるかも知れませんで次に行ったのが個別化です
それぞれの子供の特徴がわかるのでそれぞれの子供が解く問題を全部変えました
復習問題も全部変えました頻度も全部買いました
するとさっきの2倍に行くところこれが達成されました
じゃあそれは子どもにとっては不安ですけどもじゃあ親にとってはどうか
これは早急丁寧な可視化したデータを本当に単純な光景にしてを家に送っているもの
です
ちょっと小さいですけれども今週はこのくらい勉強してますとかもう朝の5分の勉強が
10日間も続いています
だとか
初めて
小学校のお姉さん向けの問題が解けるようになりましたとかそういったことをお伝えし
ています
でも中学入試の問題がこんなのあったんだけども3回ぐらい
間違ってでもめげずにやって解けたとか
フォートリーグって書いてありますけど子どもがどんな努力をしたのか可視化されてい
ます
すべてそれが統計によって行われていると
こういったメールを送ると
あめる見てどうされてますかっていうふうにユーザーの方と話すとですね褒めています
4褒めることしかやることがないと今まではマルバツを親が
つけた
で子供ができなかったら問題集ドリルをとっかえひっかえ
2人したで解けなかったらなんでできないの
みたいなことを思わず言ってしまったりしたでももうそういった作業は機械が行って
しまっているのでメールことがないと
で学校2倍進んでいるとで例えば今週初めて時計が読めるようになったと結構間違った
けど
諦めずにやったんだね偉いねっじゃあお父さんにこのデジタル時計を読んで教えて
すごいねなんて事を言うと
べっ甲言われてまあ
嬉しくない子どもはいないと
なんでこういったメールをたくさん送っています
これは日本人の自尊心についての統計調査
国際資格です
をレンズで囲ってあるところが日本人
私は他の人と同じように価値がある人だと思う
でこっち側はダメ人間だと思うこういった指標が日本はとてもあのバルクでています
年を追うごとにへ
小学校低学年中学年主が府高校行く家でどんどん下がっていっていると
さっきみたいなメールをどんどん送る事で
その後が80年生きるか100人いるかわかりませんけれども
初めの10年間やそこらで両親からそんな風に褒められることで
こういった自尊心自己肯定感が上がっていくんじゃないかなというふうに移動してい
ます
今あのこれはユーザーの方が選手を送ってくれたと察しなんですけどもまぁこんなに
勉強しているという
子どもにとっては
周りのことの方が大事で実際主観的にはこんな感じなんですよね
勉強なんてほんと一部にすぎなくて残りの遊んだり
両親と話したりそういったことをしたいと
データサイエンスも
法律性のおかげで勉強してる平均時間だいたい5分くらい5分か10分ですに備え
詰め込んでるわけじゃないとだけども
学校の2倍も進んでいると割とまあ親もまぁここまでやってるし
あのこんな時間遊ぼうかななんて言うに思ってコメントリラックスして遊んだりして
いる
ここまで
振り返ってきて
何かあっ
機械であるから
データ財布を使うから心が置いてきぼりになって
つまらない話になっているのかなと親と子の関係かの御感想になってるのかな
子供が勉強嫌いになって自尊心を失ってるのかな
そうは思わないですデータサイエンスを使うからといって心が教えられるわけではない
です
人間性の10手刀
データサービスというのは共存する概念だと私は思います
じゃあ子どもにとってはそれでいいとじゃじゃあ
を件とってはどうかもしくはこれは親ですけれども
先生にとってはどうかさっき子ような話が出ましたけれども
こういった機会がが進むことによってデータサイエンスがいろんな事をやっちゃって
ドンドン賢くなって人間がやることが
なくなってしまうんじゃないかな
っていう懸念がありますよね
どんな領域で見てきたんですけれども人の仕事がなくなるって言うのは
少なくとも急速には起こらないことだなというふうに私は予想しています
なぜかというとまるばつを上手く行ったり統計を出すのが半自動なったりする所で
子どもの成長を見守ってくれる人は欲しいですよね
コミュニケーションする人やっぱり欲しい
さっきのセカンドオピニオンの医療ロボットの話もありましたけれども
じゃあロボットがお前多分がんやと思うです
5年でしたと思うっていう風に豊かすると
人間の先生が欲しいですよね自分の治療を見守って一緒に歩いてくれる人がほしいじゃ
ないですか
なのでデータサイエンスを使ったところで人間の雇用というのは少なくとも急速には
失われないというのが私の意見です
じゃあそれでもじゃあコミュニケーションもどんどんできていろんな励ましの機会が
できるなったとしても人間が機械に勝てることそして人間が楽しいなと思えることそれ
は想像力と創造力
イマジネーションとクリエイティビティだと思います
さっき落ち言われていましたよねさっきのワークショップで
人間には
沖神があります
なので
何かを
考え出すこと
何か今までなかったことを作り出すことをやって
つまらないなって思う人はいないと思います子供はもっとオーバーに自分たちの喜びを
表現しています
機械がこれからどんどん進んでデータサイエンスが活用されて言って技術の流れ自体を
止めることというのは結構難しいと思います
だけれども
データサイエンスの特徴を知ることで何が機会にさせるべきで何が人であるべきかと
いうその境界線を理解することで私が考えることができますそれが想像力と創造力だと
思います
データサイエンスまあ
科学であって道具です
道具があるから私たちの未来が勝手に決められるわけではないと思います
私たちが
同部を使って
未来を作っていくんだと私はお前
想像力と創造力でみたよ一緒に作っていきましょう
今日はご静聴ありがとうございました